Everyone has heard the stories about what
happened back in ‘68.
The most brutal series of occult murders in
Wyoming history: Ten victims killed over a
series of four months, found with their hearts
cut out near some old cabin out in the sticks.
All these innocent people’s lives were cut
short in the service of worshipping some entity
that nobody else understood.
Thankfully, the murders had stopped by the
start of the seventies, and this humble Wyoming
county knew nothing but peace for several
years after.
But the cabin where it all happened remained
abandoned.
The ground was sour there; weighed down by
the horrors that’d transpired.
You’d need to be brave or foolish to set
foot there, all things considered.
That’s what led 17-year-old Charlie and
his reluctant girlfriend, Samantha, to that
rickety old building one cold, dark winter
night.
He was doing what most foolhardy teenage boys
tried to do with almost every action they
took: Prove himself.
Samantha was just along for the ride, despite
her protests.
Her folks had always warned her about this
place.
The word they most often used to describe
it was, “Evil.”
But Charlie wouldn’t take no for an answer.
He was going to open that rickety front door
and step inside, and Samantha would watch,
in awe of his bravery.
Though as he got closer, and felt his fingers
nearing the door handle, a pang of fear tingled
through him.
Was this really something he wanted to do?
Too late to back out now, Samantha was watching.
He couldn’t be a coward.
He needed to commit.
He needed to prove he could do this.
Charlie took a final deep breath, opened the
door, and stepped through into the dark.
He would never be seen again.
Samantha squinted and looked into the dark.
There was no “into”, really.
It was almost like a giant, black rectangle
was obscuring the doorway.
There was no way to make out any of the features
inside.
She called her boyfriend’s name with a quivering
voice and got nothing in response.
That’s when she should have started running.
It might have even saved her.
A figure emerged from the door, walking fast.
It was solid black, with no discernable features,
only a vaguely humanoid shape.
It walked towards her with such speed and
purpose that poor Samantha didn’t even have
time to scream.
The creature extended a clawed hand, and reached
through her chest - It didn’t even break
the skin, just phased through her skin, muscle,
and bone like a ghost passing through a wall.
Suddenly, she felt immense pain as the creature
drew back its hand.
It was holding something that moved and squirmed
in its clawed grip.
It was only as Samantha collapsed, her vision
going dark for the last time, that she realized
she was looking at her own, beating heart.
And this wouldn’t be where the horrors ended
for this little Wyoming town.
No, this was only the beginning.
More people would go missing in the following
days and weeks.
Wildlife and livestock would also be found
dead under mysterious circumstances.
Local vets were baffled by dead pets found
in yards with no obvious cause of death, only
to be confused and horrified when they performed
an autopsy and found massive internal bleeding,
and a missing heart.
Despite the fact that there was never any
kind of wound indicating a heart’s removal.
Your average weird occult murders are the
FBI’s problem, but when hearts start to
disappear in a mysterious fashion, that’s
how the SCP Foundation gets involved in your
case.
They dispatched a number of Field Agents into
the town in order to track down the source
of this anomalous activity, and potentially
secure and contain whatever hostile entity
was behind it.
In this case, they really didn’t need to
track the entity down: It came for them.
Three agents were driving down a lonely Wyoming
road near the cabin when a sudden series of
shapes glowed into prominence in the car’s
high beams.
It wasn’t just one of those vantablack creatures,
it was several.
The second the car ground to a halt, the entities
engaged with extreme hostility.
They attacked, seeming unaffected by conventional
arms fire from the two agents in the front
seats.
They dragged them out of the car, before reaching
into their chests and pulling out their hearts.
The agent in the back seat got lucky.
He’d had experience with beings similar
to this in the past, and had one method that
might work.
As they drew towards him, he loaded a magazine
of silver-tipped rounds into his handgun.
Closer, closer.
The agent also happened to be a devout Muslim,
and as the creatures approached, he drew his
weapon and prayed to Allah for the strength
to overcome these demons.
He opened fire, just as they were climbing
into the car and reaching for him.
For the first time, the bullets seemed to
have an effect.
The creatures squealed as the gunfire rendered
through them.
The ones dealt fatal wounds briefly convulsed,
before melting into a fine, sulphuric sludge.
The agent, thinking on his feet, noticed that
the creatures that stole the hearts of his
two fellow agents were fleeing.
He followed them, trying to find their source.
And of course, it was the cabin.
The creatures passed back through the open
door, into the darkness of the cabin.
How many of them were there?
And what was going on inside?
Naturally, the full might of the SCP Foundation
rolled into town not long after this incident.
Knowing now that the cabin - designated SCP-1983-1
- was the source of the creatures - designated
SCP-1983-2 - things were easier to get under
control.
A fake chemical plant was built around the
cabin as a pretense to keep it contained - this
plant became known as Outpost 54.
On-site researchers would sleep in the facility;
soldiers required for the regular culling
of 1983-2 instances would make their home
in the barracks.
And of course, there was also a large armory
filled with the specialized weaponry and ammunition
required to put the rampaging, heart-stealing
creatures down.
The fateful encounter that the surviving agent
had with these aggressive entities provided
the Foundation with an invaluable piece of
data on how to combat SCP-1983.
For reasons not fully understood, the 1983-2
creatures have an extreme reaction against
sincere human belief.
It doesn’t matter which religion you personally
follow, if you’re a true believer, and you
make a prayer to your deity of choice while
firing on one of these monsters with silver-based
ammunition, you will be able to slay them.
Brings a whole new meaning to the phrase “spray
and pray.”
But the belief must be truly sincere for the
attack to work.
If there is doubt or skepticism in your heart
when you’re praying and firing, well, let’s
just say it won’t be your heart for much
longer…
These very particular killing methods are
the reason that MTF Chi-13, also known as
The Choir Boys, were brought in to be the
personal stewards of 1983’s containment.
They’re a Mobile Task Force formed entirely
of devout religious believers, whose faith
girds them against the influences of a number
of occult monsters - SCP-1983 included.
The Foundation performed a series of cursory
tests on the cabin itself.
The building contained several frustrating
spatial anomalies, with the locus of these
being the front door, and the living room
behind it.
The living room seemed impossible to access
by any means other than the anomalous aperture
in the front door.
Any attempts to enter via the wall, or other
doors in the house, simply cause the researchers
to pop up in different areas of the house.
After a barrage of tests, including busting
holes in the exterior walls in an attempt
to enter - to no avail, of course - the O5
Council forbade further testing.
It simply wasn’t worth potentially creating
more openings that 1983-2 instances could
emerge from.
This left only one option: Launching excursions
into the heart of the anomaly itself via the
portal in the front door.
This seemed to be the only way to successfully
gather intel about the inner workings.
For the first of three fateful incidents,
a detachment from the Choir Boys, armed with
silver munitions, was sent into the portal.
None of them ever returned, but for the first
time in years, the front door mysteriously
closed again.
This led to a drastic reduction in the release
of SCP-1983-2 instances, but still left a
whole team potentially stranded inside.
A second detachment from the Choir Boys was
prepared to head in and, if not rescue, at
least find out what happened to the first.
They opened the door and ventured inside,
only for history to repeat itself.
Not one of them would ever be seen alive again.
And what’s more, with the door once again
open, another one of the entities soon charged
out and began attacking more Foundation researchers.
The onslaught only stopped with the brave
sacrifice of Agent Morris, a field agent stationed
at Outpost 54 at the time.
He entered the doorway and closed the door
once again from the inside.
Just like everyone else, Agent Morris was
sadly never seen alive again.
But on May 23, 1989, something remarkable
happened.
Having wasted too many agents on this anomaly
already, the Foundation decided to send in
a D-Class.
The D-Class in question was Jackson Parker,
a man whose personnel file indicated he had
a profound belief in the moral fairness of
the universe - that everything that happened
simply must have happened for a reason, even
his own incarceration.
He was given a camera with a live feed, and
a lifeline leading back outside, before practically
being pushed into the cabin.
Moments later, the lifeline was pulled taut
and snapped.
The feed cut off at around the same time.
Foundation researchers at the outpost sighed,
having lost another guinea pig.
Little did they know, Jackson Parker wasn’t
dead.
And what’s more, he was about to do what
no agent of the SCP Foundation could: Destroy
SCP-1983.
On the inside, Jackson was met with a nightmare.
This anomaly was so much worse than anyone
knew: It didn’t look like the inside of
a cabin, it was a surreal shadow dimension,
looking like a patchwork amalgamation of so
many different buildings: Hospitals, schools,
offices, homes, factories, military installations.
Jackson even recognized the dingy basement
of his childhood home among the chaos.
At that moment, it was clear - This wasn’t
just one anomalous location, it was the nexus
point for many.
How many doors were there out there, in how
many different buildings, unleashing the horrors
of SCP-1983?
Across the world?
Across dimensions, even?
Lucky for Jackson, he was about to receive
a little help from beyond the grave.
One of the Choir Boys, Agent Barclay, had
written a note before he died.
Here, he gave the few pieces of information
Jackson needed not only to survive but potentially
even destroy this thing once and for all.
First, that the entities, born from shadows,
are weaker in the dark - light gives them
form, in the dark, they’re intangible.
Second, there is no way out through the front
door: If someone tries to escape outside,
their body will melt almost instantaneously.
And most importantly of all, Agent Barclay
realized why they’d been taking the hearts:
In the center of this terrible place lies
The Nest, a giant pile of human hearts surrounded
by light sources, acting as a kind of incubator.
After being placed in the nest, the hearts
burst open, and new instances of SCP-1983-2
emerge.
If someone could destroy The Nest, it may
destroy the very heart of SCP-1983, and finally
neutralize this nightmarish anomaly.
Agent Barclay had lost his faith seeing his
friends slaughtered around him, so he didn’t
have it in himself to finish this thing.
It could only be Jackson now.
And as you know, Jackson had an unshakable
belief that everything happens for a reason.
Perhaps the reason he was here was to finally
bring an end to the suffering, and that’s
exactly what he was going to do.
Jackson shouldered Barclay’s rifle, and
charged through the labyrinth, gunning down
attacking SCP-1983-2 entities on the way.
He was a man on a mission.
Soon, he made his way into the central chamber
and finally saw it: The Nest, this horrifying
pile of wriggling human hearts.
One of the many sights that finally broke
Agent Barclay.
But Jackson stood unbroken.
He aimed the rifle at The Nest and opened
fire, the sheer force of his unshakable belief
super-charging his every shot.
He had struck a killing blow at the heart
of the beast, avenging everyone it ever murdered.
On the outside, to everyone’s amazement,
SCP-1983 disappeared.
The front door opened and the darkness dissipated
within.
When agents and researchers entered, they
found the desiccated corpses of several Mobile
Task Force members, but all signs of the previous
anomaly were gone.
From the same note left on the corpse of Agent
Barclay, it was clear to the researchers that
Jackson Parker had taken the advice, and finally
neutralized this dangerous Keter-Class anomaly.
Though Jackson himself was nowhere to be found,
he was given a posthumous medal of bravery
and merit by the Foundation - Only one of
two ever awarded to a D-Class.
I guess you could say that everything happens
for a reason.
Now go check out “SCP-3999 - I Am At The
Center of Everything That Happens To Me”
and “SCP-5049 - The Skin Salesman - Demon
Dan's Discount Homunculus Depot” for more
explorations into the hearts of genuinely
unnerving SCPs!